we've got some sad news coming out of
Xbox this morning definitely never like
to see stories like this this article is
from Gamespot says Microsoft lays off 10
000 people Cuts reportedly include Xbox
and Bethesda which comes after hiring
more than 75 000 people since 2019 and
of course also comes after spending a
whole lot of money on the Activision
Blizzard purchase this is the memo that
they sent to the staff on the official
Microsoft blog which is written by
Nadella and says we're living through
times of significant change and as I
meet with customers and partners a few
things are clear it says first as we saw
customers accelerate their digital
spending during the pandemic we're now
seeing them optimize their digital spend
to do more with less which funnily
enough could include things like Game
Pass OR also seeing organizations in
every industry and geography exercise
caution as some parts of the world are
in recession and other parts are
anticipating one and it certainly is
true that uh this is more indicative of
the times than it is necessarily of the
company there are a lot of Industries
currently anticipating a recession the
actual Microsoft blog post didn't say
who was getting laid off but Bloomberg
reported that it would be Microsoft's
Xbox and Bethesda divisions that would
be effect